[Music]
welcome to the uplift we have a great
show for you today and a great cast of
characters a woman using her hobby to
honor her son and help others a teen who
uses a silly gesture to boost the
spirits of seniors what is it you ask
we'll tell you another young girl who
battled cancer and after growing her
hair back she's cutting it all off
plus we go behind the scenes of the
monarch butterfly count and there's some
good news for the entire species and
meet a blended family who has been
through a lot but their story isn't just
one of challenges it's also about
resilience and love all that coming up
on the uplift
thank you
[Music]
hi there everyone I'm Vladimir YouTube
and this is the show that lifts you up
for at least the next 30 minutes or so
we're going to begin in Houston today
we're a young boy with autism received
the gift to lift his spirits here's
David begno
it may have started as a story about
what's wrong with the world what's
broken so this is my little dog Chloe 13
year old Carson Thompson who has autism
is now in an arm sling because he says
bullies pushed him to the ground on his
way home from the bus stop breaking his
wrist but rather than focus on what's
broken I asked his mom what might help
him heal
and she said well if he could meet a
video game designer that would make his
day so one tweet and about a dozen phone
calls later we arrived in Houston to
give him the best surprise yet hey
Carson
welcome to six foot studios and you know
what we do here
we make games this is so cool
super small what do you think about that
that's awesome that's pretty cool thank
you don't worry about bullies don't
worry about any of those things okay
there are many many people who love you
and want the best for you
hours today for you today was awesome
honestly I'm pretty inspired I think
that I am going to make the best game
ever created
[Music]
nice to meet you bud nice to meet you
too we are inspired too our next story
is about a mom who wanted to honor her
late son and found a way to do that
while also helping others here's cbs's
John lauritzen
I thought after he passed what can I do
I just I don't want his memory forgotten
Peter stahovich was an athlete a
traveler a fun-loving guy who may have
fit more into 25 years than most people
do in a lifetime he loved life he was
driven he knew what he wanted he knew
where he wanted to go but in 2019 a
cancerous brain tumor claimed Peter's
young life for Sandy the grief was so
overwhelming that she couldn't celebrate
Christmas for a couple years but then
she got an idea and then I remember that
blanket
and I go there it is while Peter was
being treated at Monticello's Cancer
Center someone gave him a blanket that
he loved so Sandy began making blankets
of her own I can't think of anything
else but the next stitch in three years
she's made 248 blankets that she donates
to cancer patients each one includes her
son's story Sandy names every blanket
she crochets and donates the colors
remind her of a memory of Peter the
names may be associated with the sports
team he loved or a place he traveled the
recipient would never really know the
memory
but I know what it is there was a
connection there a mom and son
connection that was very powerful those
who took care of Peter at the Cancer
Center aren't surprised Sandy does what
she does and I think something he did
that was very important with his mom
also was he he gave meaning to the time
he had left
Sandy has received a number of thank you
cards from patients and if she sees them
she tells them to live by some of the
last words Peter ever said
physical and and speech therapy he was
able to say don't
give up
coming up meet a 16 year old who is
dedicated to Bringing joy to seniors and
it all starts with one simple item any
guesses plus a heartwarming moment
between a mom and her four-year-old you
just need to see
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift we now have
the heartwarming videos you need to see
starting with this one from a mom named
Kaylee Compton who says her
four-year-old son has autism and is
non-verbal so she was shocked to hear
him say this for the very first time
take a listen
say mama mama
can you see Mama Mama
wait yes
Kelly says she has been dreaming of that
moment and after he said it once she got
out her phone to film it because she did
not believe it was real but it certainly
was and it was beautiful all right we
now introduce you to a teen who found a
simple way to boost the spirits of
seniors in living facilities here's CBS
Sacramento Sakura Gray
clubs gloves and golf balls when heading
out on the golf course those are usually
some of the essentials but for 16 year
old El Gianelli there's another thing to
add to the checklist I play in silly
socks I think it lightens my mood and
it's just a little good luck charm for
me it's her signature look every time
she looks down it's a reminder to keep
on smiling in 2020 that reminder was
more important than ever just a few
weeks before the world shut down
Gianelli went on a field trip to a
senior living facility just a seventh
grader at the time Gianelli was touched
by her interactions with the residents
when the pandemic hit she knew she
needed to do something for them what's
something I love that brings the smile
to my face and might bring something to
others and that was silly socks she
created socks for seniors to send fun
socks to local nursing and assisted
living facilities two years later she
sent over 3 000 socks to facilities
Across the Nation she includes a note
with each pair of socks sharing her
contact in case any seniors need someone
to talk to along the way she's gained
several pen pals they wanted me to
finish the back for them and so we sent
it back and forth to each other at just
16 years old Gianelli has been featured
in TV interviews even appearing in
People magazine but the reward of socks
for seniors is much more than that and
hearing like the response hey I just
wanted to let you know that you know
that gentleman we posted yesterday he
passed away today and the last thing he
was so excited about was that little
pair of socks for Gianelli it's about
showing these folks that someone still
cares you never know what someone's
going through so maybe something really
small such as socks can do something for
someone or me riding back to them
knowing that they have someone and that
they're not alone and they'll get
through it
people like you they will get through it
coming up a young girl decided to cut
her long locks to donate to patients
with cancer and for her the decision was
Personal Plus how are monarch
butterflies counted we will show you and
give you an up close look at the
beautiful but endangered species
foreign
[Music]
butterflies were on the verge of
Extinction in 2020 but an annual count
shows their numbers are increasing CBS
San Francisco meteorologist Darren Peck
gives us an inside look at how they
count these beautiful creatures
no I've had him land on my hat he's got
me here long enough you can see them ah
There She Goes
so you you've had them land on you like
that before oh yeah
oh sure he made that moment seem like no
big deal but Paul Mary knows better than
just about anybody else having a monarch
butterfly land on you has become an
exceedingly rare privilege in 1997 when
they first counted all the Western
monarchs there were 1.2 million
in 2020 there were less than two
thousand if you just do the math on the
numbers Paul gave us that is more than a
99 Decline and it had a lot of experts
concerned that by 2021 the Western
Monarch would be extinct now how do you
go from zero here in 2020
thirteen thousand four last year
please tell us lots of whoopee
that's one obvious part of it but it's
not the whole story turns out the last
two years the weather has been very
favorable for these guys because of
climate change now it's either way too
warm when they're not expecting it or
way too cold when they're not prepared
for it in addition to that we've
unwittingly destroyed most of their
habitat they're sort of a poster child
for
everything that's going on in the insect
world
the bottom line on this is if you can't
find enough to eat because the
wildflowers you rely on are gone because
we put so much other stuff there you're
not going to be able to survive the
winter oh what do you think anywhere
what do you think did that one end
starvation starvation
the rumble from the people who are doing
the accounting is that the State numbers
may be as high as 300 000.
which would be under 50 000 plus
improvement over last year so another
good year
but they're not out of the woods
people with long hair will often cut it
to donate to patients with cancer for
one little girl the decision to donate
her locks was personal here's CBS
Minnesota's Jennifer Mayer Lee with her
story
this is so long rose Evenson is ready to
chop her long hair I have more than
enough hair so I can give it to other
somebody who doesn't have hair that was
about 26 inches we need at least 14. the
journey to growing at this length began
a few years ago when Rose was barely old
enough to remember hi my name is Rose
and I had cancer when I was three this
letter will accompany her donation I
didn't have hair then either now my hair
is very long and I want to cut it and
share it with you we first met Rose in
late 2016. wave see if you can get him
to wave she and her sisters waved to
their garbage men forming a special
relationship and inspiring Millions
around the world with a wave and a smile
it's then we learned about her stage
four kidney and lung cancer diagnosis we
followed Rose and her family through
treatment setbacks and remission now
cancer free you made it for five years
after she had lost her hair her chemo
and radiation when it started growing
back for years she said I'm never going
to cut my hair
I think she just was glad to have hair
again so Rose's hair grew without a cut
or a trim are you nervous
no awesome now ready to share what she
has with someone like her survivors
and people whose hair have fill out and
they need hair
there it is
[Applause]
that's awesome can you believe you're
holding you here we know what it's like
to
receive when you're going through that
tough time her mom and sisters looked on
watching the transformation that's a
symbol of their Journey
it was exciting but I didn't expect to
be emotional the hair after it grew back
has just really been a reminder of God's
goodness to us
during the whole journey and that we've
come this far there's so many of them
Rose knows where her donation is going
another kid what do you think about that
is that special I am nine right now
almost 10. I hope you enjoy the wig I
have given you maybe someday you could
share your hair with somebody else love
Rose
love it up next meet the blended family
who have been through many challenges
but thanks to their love and the
kindness of strangers they show the
power of resilience
[Music]
thank you
we now introduce you to a blended family
that has gone through many challenges in
the past year but no matter what they
stayed resilient and stuck together
David begno shows us how
[Music]
as much as Gregory Hobb tried
he was unable to outsmart time
[Music]
369 loves of mine was a tribute to his
three children
It Was Written after he was diagnosed
with colon cancer and told he had just
months to live
tell me about that song I listened to it
and I love it so 369 is the ages of the
his kids so Jane Max and Henry yeah
Henry being the oldest and he just goes
through and describes um
Heather
the start either each each a love of his
and why he loves me
it's a little about them
what Greg didn't know when he wrote that
song was that he and his wife Megan were
both running out of time
Chris the Lieber is Megan's twin sister
what happened
she just died suddenly she was sitting
on the couch with her brother-in-law and
all the kids were playing upstairs
and she just took her last breath and
died four months after Greg died from
cancer Megan died due to Cardiac Arrest
she was just 40 years old
she had an undiagnosed heart condition
Krista was tasked with telling her twin
sister's children how did they react
Henry had tears right away
I just told him you know we're just
gonna be a bigger family now and we're
going to be here for you and I want you
to know you're never going to be alone
ever you're going to be taken care of
seemingly overnight 40 year old Krista
and her 37 year old husband Dave went
from three children to six one dog to
two and they did it all without even
hesitating can I have those they're just
one big gang you know the cousin crew
everything in this house comes in pairs
now
dogs
yeah girls the boys
for Henry who is now 11. the memory of
his mom and dad is ever strong I used to
have like long talks with like Daddy
Emma we like walk and talk everywhere we
just talk about the future like what
what will happen like
is nice and calm and am I miss most
about mommy just watching shows with her
talking to her like mostly just talking
like little things
I mean I missed that
it's been about four months since Megan
died
and Henry and his siblings are now
easily settling into a life with their
aunt uncle and cousins and that's in
part because of the community that
swarmed in when their world came
crashing down after Greg died and then
after Megan died there was this Village
of people some strangers right who came
together and said what to you how can we
help what can we do some people would do
something as small as help with a cat
other people donated lots of money there
was nothing too small and nothing too
big and I it all added together to like
be this kind of unified front of
stability for the kids and because of
that support in the midst of
insurmountable grief there has been Joy
the laughter the children just being
kids extended family all huddled
together around the Thanksgiving table
decorating the Christmas tree taking the
new family Christmas photo
there have been lessons too for everyone
like making your health a priority
you see shortly after Greg died Dave was
diagnosed with an autoimmune disease had
you been putting off how you were
feeling for a while yeah I was feeling
things and things were happening and I
just chalked it up too
stress then came Christa's Health shock
that she thought was stress you started
feeling something funny I had been
feeling
palpitations and shortness of breath
since
either the pandemic or Greg's cancer
diagnosis both the same time but that's
around when I started feeling it
and I felt like my sisters is just
anxiety but after her twin sister died
Krista decided to get her heart checked
just in case and what did they tell you
I have a Long QT syndrome
which is
your heart
has an electrical conductivity issue it
can cause sudden death fainting seizures
I told daylight
my sister saved my life you know her I
say her death was not in vain
there's a bigger picture here
and how old are the twins
one everything that this family has been
going through reminds them that life is
fragile
but with the help of a village and with
unwavering love
life marches only because it has to
because the alarm clock still goes off
in the morning the school bell still
rings
beyond the grief the hop kids have found
happiness in this home how would you
describe the kids now
I love them I love them so much
um
they are really resilient they're okay
they truly are they're okay and no we
may not be able to outsmart time
but maybe it's not about that anyway
who's that
yeah looks like me yeah what is the
takeaway
don't wait for tomorrow to come
here in this moment rely on the kindness
of strangers when it comes
thank goodness for counseling and the
school's involvement and the kinds of
these strangers
and all the friends and family that have
surrounded us and made us feel love
because these kids feel it too
we all do
[Applause]
[Music]
a beautiful story beautifully told by
David begno that is our show I hope this
news brightened your day and lifted you
up
foreign